le président de la chambre de métiers de
l'artisanat et danse arcady ce matin
bonjour henry salomon bonjour monsieur
violent et bonjour à tous les
martiniquais et surtout artisans
martiniquais vous êtes avec nous quand
c'est la semaine de l'artisanat qui bat
son plein et nous sommes également henri
salomon en pleine campagne pour les
élections présidentielle et législatives
avez vous l'impression que ce secteur de
l'artisanat est suffisamment présent
dans le discours des uns et des autres
dans les programmes des candidats
mon impression est allé partager ce
qu'ils ne sont pas assez présents donc
les candidats donc surtout aux niveaux
nationaux doivent s'intéresser de plus
près à l'artisanat aujourd'hui un
constat donc économique qui est celui
d'un échec je pense à l'emploi à
l'apprentissage à l'insertion des jeunes
il faut revoir il faut qu'ils revoient
donc leur approche de l'artisanat qui
soit plus proche des artisans des
organisations professionnelles parce que
l'artisanat créer des emplois en france
peut permettre d'attirer des jeunes
évoluant en france vous le rappelez vous
parlez bien de secteur à l'apport
économique et social vital pour le pays
absolument absolument donc je vois de ce
taux de chômage énorme au niveau
national au niveau local aussi donc une
des réponses et l'apprentissage et pour
ça il faut qu'il y ait des entreprises
solides des êtres des entreprises avec
de l'activité et pour moi il faut
prioriser l'activité en france et dans
les dom
nous avons tous une bonne raison de
choisir l'artisanat les campagnes de
promotion sur ce secteur joue volontiers
sur la proximité sur réseau personnes
qui connaissent bien leur métier
le secteur qui sait aussi et c'est très
important absorbé 80 % des apprentis
formés
absolument donc nous avons donc se
mérite au niveau de l'apprentissage et
il n'y a pas que que l'artisanat c'est
que 80% des jeunes qui à l'issue de leur
formation en apprentissage vont trouver
un métier c'est à dire ils vont être
embauchés et ça c'est une vraie réussite
par rapport au système scolaire
classique donc ça prouve que plus qu'un
diplôme apprendre un métier est une
force pour pouvoir s'insérer dans la vie
professionnelle quel regard les
martiniquais ont-ils sur ce secteur de
l'artisanat excuse à l'impression qu'il
est très très bien connu qui est très
très bien apprécié à sa juste valeur
un son plutôt un regard positif sur
l'artisanat mais aujourd'hui nous avons
un travail à faire sur sur l'image de
l'artisanat qui a changé qui a évolué
aujourd'hui d'artisanat ces nouvelles
technologies c'est la performance aussi
bien dans des métiers que je dirais
basiques comme le boulanger donc là tout
le monde sait que c'est de l'artisanat
mais le métier de boulanger l'oea a
changé il ya des produits fabuleux des
méthodes de fabrication aussi qu'ils ont
changé pour devenir plus confortable
pour ces artisans qui ont des machines
qui leur permettent de ne pas rester
éveillé toute la nuit donc ça c'est des
messages à faire passer ceux ci de 200
et il sait plus de 200 métiers plus de
200 métiers et plus de 500 activités
différentes
ces onze mille trois cents artisans que
nous recensons en martinique
voilà près de onze mille artisans seize
mille emplois donc eu plus de 850
création d'entreprises chaque année donc
c'est important et surtout donc en ce
qui concerne la chambre de métiers 625
apprentis donc ils sont formés donc
pourra arriver un but avoir un diplôme
et surtout en bout de course
sincères et donc trouver un travail
rires dépit de tout cela l'artisan est
quand même concurrencer dans l'esprit de
monsieur tout le monde
concurrencé par le fameux joober
effectivement donc là il ya un travail à
faire il ya un travail déjà nos hommes
politiques on va travailler à faire pour
pouvoir protéger ses entreprises qui
produisent qui paye des charges et qui
embauche qui insère des jeunes est aussi
un casque locaux et elles peuvent faire
là-dessus à bien mettre des lois en
place qui vont permettre de vraiment à
d'encadrer donc là une production
artisanale qui respectent une production
d'oeufs
économique qui respecte la conférence
donc ça c'est très important parce que
quand vous travaillez beaucoup quand
vous investissez beaucoup vous voulez
que ce soit donc à armes égales avec vos
concurrents
il ne faut pas que des doigts donc bien
permettre de mobiliser le jeu il faut le
rappeler
henri salomon l'artisanat c'est un chant
très très 20 cm il faut quand même être
dûment enregistrés auprès des instances
auprès de votre chambre consulaire
notamment oui c'est une des principales
missions de notre chambre de métiers
enregistré des entreprises donc nous
avons acf qui accorde qui accueille les
créateurs d'entreprises qui les
conseille sur le statut à choisir après
donc une fois enregistrés en fonction de
leur diplôme en fonction de l'expérience
ils vont avoir le titre d'artisan
mais tous y pensent lorsque vous voulez
créer une entreprise en fonction de
votre activité vous êtes orienté bain
soit vers l'artisanat soit vers le
commerce soit vers la maison des
artistes
donc là c'est très important
d'accompagner donc tous ces créateurs et
il ya vraiment donc une vraie activité
une vraie et je veux dire un bouillon de
création au niveau des petites
entreprises donc nous nous sommes
préparés nous moderniser notre outil non
pour passer donc à la digitalisation
pour accompagner aussi des chefs
d'entreprise au numérique parce qu'ils
ont besoin de mieux utiliser donc cet
outil aujourd'hui même donc nous avons
une formation dans le cadre de
la semaine de l'artisanat qui est donc
comment accomplir ces formalités en
ligne c'est à dire en oublie le papier
on passe au tout numérique et le profil
le profil type de l'artisan martiniquais
ce sont des jeunes où ce sont des vieux
cons voix font duper des vieux des
personnes d'un certain âge d'une
certaine expérience qui sont derrière
leur petit comptoir et l'enfant il est
multiple et c'est vraiment la richesse
de l'artisanat vous avez des jeunes
créateurs des jeunes faute aura déjà le
bijoutier des gens qui travaillent dans
les nouvelles technologies et des
graphistes qui sont souvent donc en
dessous de 30 ans quand ils vont
commencer ce sont des gens qui sont
diplômés se présentèrent également par
exemple la prothèse dentaire aussi
également et puis vous avez des
champions qui ont plus d'expérience qui
sont artisans parce que leurs parents
leur était donc il ya eu cette
transmission va ça aussi c'est très
important et nous devons accompagner la
transmission d'entreprises parce que
c'est une transmission de patrimoine
vous avez des artisans donc j'allais
dire dans les coeurs de ville dans notre
agglomération kacem et vous en avez et
sont l'une dans le nord dans le sud dans
les fameuses carte de la proximité
bah oui dans la proximité et ça c'est un
des enjeux aussi de notre mandature
c'est de rapprocher la chambre de
métiers de tous les artisans nous avons
l'intention de nous déployer sur le nord
atlantique sur le nord caraïbes et dans
le sud pour pouvoir être plus proche de
nos artisans et qu'ils aient moins
d'embouteillages à faire à des heures
d'embouteillages à faire pour atteindre
leurs chambres de métiers mais le plus
grand piège pour l'artisan s'est pas
cette concurrence puisque nous sommes on
parle beaucoup de mondialisation nous
sommes planète il suffit de cliquer sur
internet peut-être pour avoir le même
produit absolument les temps ont changé
le plus grand piège pour l'artisan c'est
de croire qu'on va rester dans un
protectionnisme
aujourd'hui donc sauvegarder l'artisanat
et c'est ce qui se fait et j'en suis le
témoin masse et la performance et
l'excellence donc c'est la formation de
nombreux artisans se forment maîtrise de
nouvelles techniques maîtrise de
nouveaux outils investissent et c'est
par la qualité que l'artisanat se va se
différencier de toutes ces marchandises
importées
quand on consomme un produit artisanal
ou un service artisanale mais en
consomme locale en consommer intelligent
on a aussi des produits qui respectent
plus l'environnement parce que certains
vont être fabriqués ici ne sont pas
importés de l'autre bout de
de la planète se retrouvent dix ans
qu'on sait d'où ça vient
voilà avec l'artisanat donc on avait
vraiment une consommation plus
intelligente et ça c'est important ce le
message que je fais passer à tous les
martiniquais
m consommer intelligemment consommé près
de chez vous consommez laquelle elle à
conclure cela non plus rance des tarifs
qu'est-ce qu'on peut y faire bien la
concurrence des tarifs elle est là mais
là je te parle de consommation
intelligente quand vous avez acheté
quelque chose de pas cher mais que de
vous devez le jeter au bout de quelques
jours parce que c'est de la mauvaise
qualité
il ya un proverbe qui dit bon marché
qu'a coûté cher mais ça c'est une
réalité de la vie de l'artisanat donc
choisissez la qualité choisissez donc il
ya des gens qui sont près de chez vous
parce que en plus en investissant et en
consommant pour l'artisanat vous allez
permettre d'embaucher des jeunes
et là on entend souvent parler de
vieillissement de la population pourquoi
il ya ce vieillissement de la population
parce que nos jeunes ne trouvent pas de
travail ici donc il faut qu'ils puissent
travailler ici donc il faut qu'il puisse
y avoir plus d'entreprises qui
produisent en martinique dont neuf
forcément des entreprises artisanales et
pour tous ces jeunes qui n'ont pas la
chance de pouvoir faire partir faire des
études à bien à l'extérieur il faut
aussi qu'ils puissent se former
intelligemment ici c'est à dire de
réforme des formations qui amène à un
métier et pas de la formation juste pour
de l'information parce que je me bats
aussi contre sarre et donc il faut
former intelligent il faut former avec
les professionnels connaître les noms
finances et qui finance cette formation
et l'information déjà toutes les
entreprises free fille dans sa formation
et puis avec vos impôts vous financez
aussi la formation et la formation et l
adapter aux besoins de de la martinique
par exemple c'est ce que je suis en
train de vous dire donc il faut qu'elle
soit encore plus pertinente est vraiment
que l'on s'appuie sur les professionnels
pour faire les formations dont la
martinique a besoin c'est bien c'est
vous les gens en formation
juste pour les mettre en formation c'est
vous chanterez d'amitié par exemple qui
pouvait dire aux politiques voilà ce
qu'il nous faut comme formation pour
demain c'est notre mission donc
quotidiennement nous informant donc déjà
au niveau local la ctn de nos besoins en
formation puisque c'est par exemple qui
vont financer l'apprentissage en disant
voilà dans telle filière on a besoin de
tant de personnes de tant de personnes
et ça c'est la mission de l'ag vous avez
l'impression que les élus vous écoute et
bien aimé écoute et nous écoutent oui
maintenant
ce que je veux moi c'est de l'action
donc cédé moyen concret et j'espère
avoir un frère prochainement une
université des métiers moderniser
puisque quand je parle de qualité de
performance puis de résister aussi au
vieillissement de la population il faut
qu'on puisse former des jeunes ici avec
vraiment des outils modernes et donc
notre université des métiers doit être
un véritable campus des métiers avec des
techniques des moyens pédagogiques
modernes adaptées à 21e siècle la
semaine nationale de l'artisanat on l'a
dit on est en plein dedans jusqu'au 17
mars
principale caractéristique enquête le
monde puisqu'une sont pris par le temps
alors caractéristique c'est que bien ça
va être la fête de tous les artisans
nous mettons la lumière sur l'artisanat
donc nous organisons mercredi un
déplacement avec des élus donc avec des
visites d'entreprises nous avons choisi
le nord atlantique parce que nous
voulons aussi montrer que bien que nous
sommes partout donc nous allons visiter
trois entreprises dans le nord
atlantique une entreprise dans le btp
une note dans les métiers d'art et une
autre dans les métiers de services
il va y avoir aussi donc de nombreux
témoignages demain il y aura aussi bien
on parle d'une nouvelle technologie dont
la chambre de métiers aura lui une
visioconférence où nous serons en
relation directement avec paris donc une
autre réseau national pour parler du
financement des entreprises
merci henri salles au moins rappelle
également que vous avez fait appel à des
personnalités pour venir découvrir ce
monde de l'artisanat marseillais merci
d'avoir été un rythme en de salomon
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
la chambre des métiers de l'artisanat
[Musique]